e
when we because we've got we got Ryan
Casey here his daughter Morgan helped
that of the education committee uh today
our task before us is to look at 24
bills which we recommend inome study
during the past session and as a
reminder to folks uh when we have a bill
that's inter room study we can make
uh
basically two
recommendations uh however we have a
another recommendation that committees
are doing right now and I'll go through
them the first recommendation we can
make is we recommend this legislation
for future legislation so we recommend
that it move forward
uh often times that can be done with uh
with a caveat that moved forward with
some
changes um the second motion is not
recommending a leg a piece of
legislation for future legislation so
that would just be basically saying no
and the last one and we've seen this
number of times in committees throughout
the house here where they we've come out
with a 1010 no recommendation type vote
and that's why often times we ended up
with 24 in inter room study uh the
the verbich that would be used to
reflect that in the in the counter would
be unable to reach a consensus of
whether to recommend further legislation
or not so that's what you would see in
the calendar and and the and the chair
of the committee here would be putting
that uh recommendation forward that
would be
myself so we're looking at POS three
outcomes coming from this before we get
into US I'd like to welcome everybody to
our committee today and I'd like to go
through the committee here see we have a
number of substitutes on the committee
today so I'm just going to start
wandering around through the committee
here and everybody can introduce
themselves we start out with you
representative Balon and would you
please just you know introduce yourself
to everybody so they ref familiarize
themselves with you and if you're a
regular member you might say that as
well and and uh go ahead hi everyone I'm
representative Peggy B I represent
Rockingham District 38 which is Ry
Greenland and Northampton and I've been
a member of uh was elected in 2022 and
I've been a member of the House
Education
you good morning I am representative
Karine cascaden I represent Coos um
County District 5 the city of Berlin and
um I am completing my first term
two-year term and I have been serving on
the education
committee hello everyone again hope
you're well my name is Valerie McDonnell
and I'm from walkingh Ham 25 which is
Salem this is my first term and I've
been on the education committee
thanks my name is Steve Boyd I'm from
marac District 10 I've been a member of
what else am I say and you're
substituting today and I'm substituting
today I sit on labor in Eda thank
you I'm Patty Cornell um from Manchester
Ward 11 and this is my
committee good morning I'm Linda Tanner
I represent Sullivan District 5 the
towns of sunap and Springfield and I do
live in cipe and I've been uh in the
state house for five terms thank
you Dave luno uh representing people of
Hopkinson and Bo and um uh finishing my
fifth term uh three terms here on the
education
committee I'm Lucius parall I represent
terville maror Nelson Sullivan and
Roxberry and I sit on the St uh Science
Tech and energy committee uh for the
past couple of terms but I've have 20
years experience education so I'm used
to working with
children uh Glenn cordelli representing
tuon Boro wolfboro and oopy and uh this
is uh my 12th year on the education
committee and for members of the public
I'm Rick lad I come from hail I
represent hail permont Warren Benton
landf uh I've been on the committee
education committee for 16
years I'm Margaret dry and I represent
Sullivan district 7 which is planfield
and Cornish Newport unity in Charlestown
uh this is my first term and I've been
on the education
committee Wayne McDonald I represent
Rockingham County District 16 I'm in my
second term I usually serve on the house
Health and Human Services and education
um excuse me Health Human Services Nell
Affairs committee and I'm substituting
for representative Alicia lias this
morning good morning I'm Kristen Noble I
represent Hillsboro District 2 the town
committee good morning I'm Uriel Hall uh
represent Bo and hopkington I'm
finishing my second term and currently
education good morning everyone happy
fall I'm hope Damon I represent half of
Sullivan County Sullivan District 8
towns of aworth Langdon lemster Goan
Washington Springfield cipe my hometown
of Cen and the City of Claremont say
that fast um and I uh appreciate very
much the honor and responsibility of
being on education committee and the
well hi my name is Mir Heath and I've
served in the house for six terms I am
kind of an ongoing um ass a sub for art
Ellison and um my main committee is the
finance committee and I to I'm from
Manchester New Hampshire um uh District
morning Steve Wood Clark from the m
Washington Valley representing Conway
six years on the education
committee good morning my name is Moren
Mooney a state representative from the
town of miramac located in Hillsboro
County District 12 in my fifth term in
the New Hampshire house currently
serving on the house finance committee
and glad to be with you in now House
Education for today thank
you good morning I'm Paul Terry uh and I
represent bellnap district 7 Barnstead
and Alton I'm in my second term
finishing up my second term um I served
previously on the Commerce and consumer
affairs committee uh in February I was
named to fill a vacancy here on the
education committee where I've been
thanks Karen Reed um I represent uh
Hillsboro District 27 that is Francis
town and daring I'm completing my first
term and I uh sit on criminal justice
and Public
Safety thank you very much uh just one
other item for the public um during the
previous two years uh FY 23 and 24 the
education committee had more bills than
any other Committee in the history of
this house has ever had we had 235 bills
in this one Committee of which we've
retained or interim study uh 24 of them
uh we're looking at a rule change for
the next year it's very difficult for us
to do really down research work on some
of the bills which really necessitate
that we've been looking at education
funding bills we have catastrophic Aid
we've been looking at school building
Aid Career Technical education higher
education and there's a number of
concurrent dual enrollment there's a
number of issues which are pretty heady
issues and and important for this State
and so in looking at trying to divide
the education committee up as has been
done in past years or some others you
know criminal justice uh Judiciary used
to be a singular committee it's been
divided up into another one right now as
well criminal justice um we we need to
do that with
education uh so we can get this work
done and done properly and not that we
haven't been put our nose to it and
really working hard to accomplish that
but it's been an intensive intensive
last several years and a lot of time
spent by this committee and I like to
congratulate the people on the education
committee most committees meet maybe
once or twice at Max a week we can count
on four days on many of these days not
including the session day and it's been
very very you know difficult and so by
spreading the wealth amongst two
separate education committees I think
we're going to be able to do a uh a the
type of work that I think the Public's
expecting us to do and I I hope that U
that will net some benefits to us so
without any belaboring we're going to
get on these interim study bills right
here we're going to take them
numerically uh so the we'll start with
the lowest number first and that would
be uh
HB
623 and that bill was inter studied and
it's establishing a teacher candidate
loan uh forgiveness
program and I'd like to look for a
motion on that yes represent the hall I
make a motion that we recommend uh HB
legislation is there a second of that
motion okay we have a motion on the
floor to interim study uh for interim
study they would recommended for future
discussion represent Hall thank you Mr
chair um I I just think this program
makes a lot of sense in terms of
Recruitment and
Retention of uh teachers so I think it's
a good
idea represent cordelli yes I uh I have
an issue with uh loan
forgiveness um what about uh um people
who have already paid off their
loans um I I think that there um is some
uh
unfairness um built into such a program
as provided for in this bill so I am uh
um a no on
this I'd like to also speak to it um
this previous year we did pass
legislation dealing with folks which
come out with debt and over a period of
4 years amount part of that debt is paid
off the problem was I think we only
funded it or appropriated $1 dollar for
it as a state and so it's uh we borrowed
that legislation from
Idaho um and I'm concerned that in in
passing these by from the policy
perspective but then seeing no dollars
allocated and it kind of appears that
that's the way it's going to be during
the next bium here so I too will not be
supporting the motion that it move
forward for future
legislation further discussion Madam
clerk would you please call the role Mr
chair any chance we could do this by
hand sure and that way we can keep these
things move it along that'd be great
second I got to do the same way yeah
we'll just all those that support the
motion the motion would be recommending
for fut legislation please put your
hands up we'll just count
them
one 10 10 okay those opposed put your
please 10 okay that's pretty easy to
figure
uh and I'm assuming that we go the other
way it's going to be the same
boote so is there any need to travel
down
that I just checked in with Jin he said
we need to dooll call votes for the Okay
so we've been told we have to do roll
call votes do roll call yeah nice try
nice
try I I appreciate the try because it
expedites okay so those will go back on
623 those that are supporting
recommendation for it the motion was
recommending for future legislation
would you please call the RO Madam clerk
thank you Vice chairman cordelli no
representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representative Mooney no
representative Terry
no representative
parall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes and chairman
lad no and total 10 yays 10 Nays okay
now normally what we do is we go with
the other motion and not recommend
future legislation but I'm assuming
correct me if I'm wrong anybody on the
committee that it's going to come out at
1010 so with that the the chair will
write the the uh final action of this
committee is unable to reach a consensus
of whether to recommend further
legislation or
notation so it's without recommendation
it's it's recommend further it's we're
un able to come to consensus regarding a
recommendation to either move forward or
not so so so Mr chair and and I suspect
there may be other
votes that come out like this 1010 and
so it will be that prescriptive language
it will be the same language that I just
read unable to reach a consensus of
whether to recommend further legislation
or not right and that and and so has
nothing to do with the merits of the
bill at all exactly correct exactly all
right I believe that that language came
from the house clerk that's my
understanding yes it did thank you yes
it did is that the motion writing here
well the the it was recommended for
future legisl at 1010 so we have no
recommendation and so the yeah and so on
that SLI I think you can just write
without recommendation yeah okay so yeah
without Jen is that what other
okay fine okay we're going to move on to
HB 1176 this is establishing a
commission to study current funding for
special education and potential other
funding
sources represent
he um thank you Mr chair um I would move
that um House Bill 1176 not be
forward you're you're talking about
recommending for future or not rec not
not recommending for future second we
are recommending we are recommending
early you are I actually am not all
right I vote for representative Heath's
motion all right I'm sorry I'm I would
like to recommend that we do
move inial back and
your the problem certainly isn't solved
and I I apologize too that the subs on
the committee can't make the Motions oh
well sells
that yeah see she's longterm sub though
no she's actually been seated she's been
replaced represent I'm actually
officially appointed by the speaker
you're officially appointed by Sherm
okay so you're good to go so your
recommendation clarify it one more time
for me to clarify my motion is my motion
is for HB 1176 is to make a
recommendation to move forward
okay good job Mary is there a second to
that motion I'll second that okay
representative made representative Heath
made the motion to recommend for future
legislation and second by represent luno
any further discussion from the maker of
the
motion from the second
no any further discussion amongst the
committee Madam clerk will you please
call the
RO the RO the motion is recommend for
future legislation Vice chairman
cordelli no representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representative Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock no oh
yes I sit next to Mary's K
yeah representative Hall yes
representative balbon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes and chairman
lad no 10 y 10
Nays same deal as the last bill do we
need another motion or is we are you
willing to have the you know the
language unable to reach a consensus of
whether to recommend further legislation
or not
okay okay so we're moving on now to
1185 this is a relative to sexual
education
instruction Mr chair yes um do you want
to take um yes motion first and then
or well I'm trying to do it in an
expeditious way so yeah how would you
well so I'm going to look around and if
I see a hand up for a motion okay I'm
going to go after that hand and whether
it's one way or the other we're probably
place so represent dmon your hands
flying thank you Mr chair I recommend
that
House Bill 1185 do not be recommended
for further
legislation that a not that is a not
that any discussion from the maker of
the
motion I think we know what we discussed
this spring I agree further discussion
from the
committee okay the motion on the floor
is to not recommend recommend hb1 85 for
future legislation Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli
no representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald calar
right
yes representative
Noble
no representative Boyd
no yeah representative Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parall
yes motion is not so yes thank
you representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes and chairman
lad
eight okay so there would be a
recommendation that that not move
forward
who made that most represent D and you
blur the original blur can be found in
6 okay going on to the next bill hb1
yes no
okay HB 1216 relative cross District
bullying and cyber buling
representative McDonald do you want to
make a motion uh yes thank you I
recommend that we do recommend this for
uh future legislation that's my motion
okay is there a
second I'll second it bullying instances
that inspired this bill and I think it's
an important issue that we take a
further look
at I have nothing further to add to that
is there any further
discussion Madam clerk we're ready to
call the role here on this HB
1216 relative cross District bullying
and cyber bullying the recommendation is
recommend for future
legislation Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes Representative
parall no representative Cornell no
representative t
no Representative luno no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Boni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
representative Heath no represent
chairman lad
yes 10 y 10
n I'm assuming now we're at 1010 the
same type of you know recommendation
unable to come to consensus and thank
that now we have a several bills that
are next coming up um
1383 this deals with Cooperative School
Board school
districts elections um we also have
several other bills on the docket here
dealing with cooperatives
today
um we' like to be able to tie all this
uh I know we have representative
spillsbury you're here I'm just going to
ask you a question that you and I spoke
on the horn here not too long ago
um have you come with any uh idea
yourself as to how to address these um
in terms of are you combining them all
into one bill or are you going to be
going singularly for each bill on the
Cooperative school districts have you
this thank
you is there I'm going to open this up
to a little discussion in the here first
before we take any recommendations here
um is there any discussion amongst the
committee members here on this on these
four
bills yes representative Corell yes this
is a question even if we say no can't
somebody just do it anyway that's that's
going to happen that's going to happen
that's why this is you know we're just
going through some hoops here we're
going through the
hurdles okay so what we'll do is no for
the discussion here we're just going to
go through and take a motion here on uh
Rel uh 1383 relative Cooperative School
District elections represent cordelli do
you have a a motion yes I would like to
uh move that this be recommended for
further legislation is there a
second I'll
second represent Noble second represent
cordell's motion to recommend for future
legislation any discussion represent
cordelli no
NOP no any further discussion from the
committee not seeing any Madam clerk
would you please call the role Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
McDonald yes representative Reed yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Mooney yes representative Terry yes
Representative parall no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representa luno no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Boni no Representative
cascaden no representative Danon D and
representative Heath no chairman lad yes
votes 10 y 10
days all good with what we're going to
do
here okay uh going on down to
1402 establishing a procedure for high
school proficiency exam waiver of
mandatory School
1402 represent Cornell I move that this
not be for brought forward for further
legislation I'll second it okay we have
a motion made by representative Cornell
and second by representative Tanner to
not move this uh for future
legislation discussion from the maker no
second no
committee Madam
yes Vice uh representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
voyd yes representative Mooney yes
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes and chairman lad yes 20 a zero
Jennifer 4 are any of these being put on
to consent when we get something like a
20 I thought
so
so you have to write you have to write
blue on these bills has already been
made yeah yeah yeah no further yeah yeah
yeah
no yeah
yeah the cost factor for that represent
Cornell and annual base be
$163,000 or more that's part of the
issue yes represent McDonald I have a
procedural question yes if it was a 101
who were unable to write reach consensus
is there a report written or who's
responsible the report is what I write
and unable to reach consensus oh okay
and just be the one sentence on that
bill yeah great yeah that's what they've
done in other committees too as well
it's moving quickly okay going down to
the next bill um HB 1443 relative to
resolution represent Bon I'd like to
make a motion not to move forward with
future
legislation is there any second
represent Tanner seconds the motion
motion made by representative B Balon
second by representative Tanner
any discussion from the maker the second
no any further discussion from the
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry nay representative McDonald
yes representative Noble yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Mooney yes representative Terry yes
representative parshall yes
representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes chairman lad
okay going
on 19 to1
yeah you don't have to write a whole lot
in those things just a line or two is
all you have to do you can look at the
prior committee reports that we did on
that pardon me it would just a couple
sentences really yeah yeah even if he
can do it in
one I'll try thank you all righty let's
go to the next one HB 148
1458 relative to authorizing parents to
remove children from the English
program looking for a
motion representative cordelli uh I move
that it not be
rep represent Terry had a second so okay
motion made by represent cordelli second
by representa Terry uh this on HB
1458 relative to authorizing parents to
remove children from the English
language learning program representative
cordelli do you have anything to
say uh no represent
committee it's not to recommend
as we've been told by Doe it violates
federal
law um so Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative mcdonal yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes and chairman lad yes 20 Ys
zero
Nays HB 1481 relative appointments to
fill vacancies to atlarge Cooperative
School Board seats represent cordelli uh
yes I recommend that I move that this be
recommended for further legislation is
there a
second I'll second represent Noble
seconds the motion made by represent
cordelli uh represent cordelli You' like
to speak to your
motion uh I don't think it's necessary
thank you represent Noble nope further
discussion on the bill the motion is to
1481 Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes Representative
parall no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
Representative danan no representative
Heath no and chairman lad yes 10 y 10
days same report and this one unable to
reach
consensus okay going on down
1493 relative to the powers and duties
of coopertive School District budget
committees represent cordelli ditto
yes the motion is he's made to move it
forward is there we hold little time for
the clerk here to to catch up is there a
second yet no we have not had a second
yet is there a second to the motion
second Noble seconds the
motion represent cornelli do you have
anything to say on on the bill I do
not represent Noble no further
discussion from the
committee the motion is to move uh 1493
Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes Representative
parall no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
albon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no representative
Heath no chairman lad yes 10 Y and 10
n okay everybody knows what the blur's
going to
say okay um going on down to the next
bill
159 prohibiting spending of special
education monies for any other purpose
and requiring reporting of fund balances
to the school board I'll pass the gaval
off to representative cordelli uh thank
you and I will uh call upon uh chairman
lad for a motion I'd like to make a
motion that the bill not move forward
for legislation is there a second I'll
second that representative luno seconds
uh chairman lad do you have any to add
NOP repres
luno anyone else on the committee any
comments great Madame
Ali Vice
oh who do I start
with start with me okay chairman lad yes
Vice chairman cordelli yes represent
McDonald yes representative Reed yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald
no representative Noble
no representative Boyd yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Terry
yes Representative parshall no no
representative yes hold on yes
yes representative partial yes yeah it's
yes okay representative Court
yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath
yes 18 Ys two Nays and for those who may
be interested in some of the rationale
why that was put forward you can go to
house Journal 8 page five and and see
the rationale for
it okay HB 1516 relative to enrollment
in public schools by children of School
hall for HB 1516 not recommend for
future
legislation is there a second I'll
second that okay represent Hall makes
the motion uh to not recommend for
future legislation and second by
representative Tanner any further
discussion from the maker of the
motion from the second
discussion
right Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry nay representative McDonald
no representative
Noble no representative Boyd no
representative Mooney yes representative
Terry yes representative parall yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Hall oh sorry
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative
cascaden yes oh I'm sorry representative
B Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative dman yes representative
Heath yes and chairman lad
yes 16 y 4
n again if people want to look up the
rational why you go to House calendar 6
page four and it will show you the pre
previous uh committee
report
um so represent Hall that's calendar 6
page four you're can find a prior
committee report you can copy a lot of
stuff right out there uh HB
1534 this is Rel is I jump one no that's
no 1534 rela to establishing a program
to earn tuition credits for State of New
Hampshire higher education institutions
through community service it was a
student to yeah we have a student here
so special
now introduce yourself and press the red
the red button and introduce yourself
School
Etc first off thank you for giving me
the opportunity to say a few words my
name is Ryan Casey and I'm a junior at
Bishop Brady High School my sister
Morgan Casey and I have worked on this
bill over the last year she presented it
to the committee last January with with
representative Schultz and is currently
in
college I am passionate about education
it's the engine that drives Ingenuity
entrepreneurship business medicine the
economy and
Beyond I feel it's imperative to find a
way to make higher education attainable
and affordable to everyone that is
interested in pursuing
it there is also value in serving the
community and getting to know New
Hampshire outside of the
classroom this legislation was a first
step and I've received valuable feedback
from some of the committee members I've
come to realize that starting the
program on a limited scale and growing
it will provide more accurate
information on the potential cost of
this
program I value and welcome the
committee's input and I'm hoping to put
forward a scaled down version in the
near future thank you thank you very
much yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I move that we
recommend this bill for further legisl
is there a
that okay we have a motion made by
representative Damon second by represent
luno to move HB 1534 for future
legislation further discussion from the
maker I just want to thank Ryan for his
them further yes i' I'd also like to
thank um um Ryan Casey and and his
sister Morgan for um uh for for bringing
this concept forward and following it
through all of the the committee process
the uh the votes on the house floor and
I think this is a tremendous exercise in
um in Civics and uh and how to how to
lead policy development uh here in New
Hampshire and um and it's been a real
real privilege for us to have uh to have
you and your sister uh involved D in
this so thanks so much for your diligent
work on this obviously no promises on
how uh on how this comes out but really
look forward to um to your your further
work in in uh in bringing this idea back
so thank you very much
Ryan and go ahead representative
McDonald well said may I add but Mr
chair may I request a caucus
please yes if you would like you're
requesting a caucus we're going to take
a five minute break for a caucus
and we're going to have to clear the
room
um Republicans will stay in in here
here
e
okay we're ready to go back back into uh
session
here and we have a motion on the floor
this is
1534 relative to establishing a program
to earn tuition credits for state New
Hampshire higher education institutions
through community service the motion is
uh the bill be put forward for future
legislation Is there further discussion
on the yes representative thank you Mr
chair and I'd like to say thank you to
you and your sister as well I think a
lot of us can recognize the Merit in the
idea and look forward to seeing perhaps
what you bring forward next if the cost
is reduced or maybe some more extensive
analysis on how the cost is determined
but um so to clarify my vote is in
support of the idea and not necessarily
the fiscal amount and I think I speak
for quite a few of us when I say that
but thank
you yeah if you look at the write up
that the doe did on this they took a
hypothetical that we know we have 52,000
plus high school students in the
state if 20% took advantage of the
program that's about 10,000
kids $2500 times the 10,000 students
would be $25 million a year and
obviously that's out of the ballpark uh
however this concept has a lot of
Merit and so
I think you said scale back in your
presentation to us I think that's good
thing to be looking at so as it further
discussion on the yes represent Damon so
I would just acknowledge as the maker of
the motion that I would be happy to
include in the report that the concept
has significant Merit but it needs more
fiscal analysis and a really careful
look at further development of thank you
very much PR thank you okay further
discussion on the bill not seeing any
Madam clerk would you please call the
RO who second that one Lun pardon me
luno they
okay Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative
Reed yes representative dry nay
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney no
representative Terry no
representative parshall yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes chairman lad yes 17 Ys three
Nays thank you very much thank you for
coming
today uh going on to the next bill HB
1555 this is relative to special
education special meetings for changes
in education
funding I'll make a motion go ahead to
re I um I'd like to um to recommend 1555
be recommended for future legislation is
there a second on that I'll second it we
have motion made by representative luno
second by representative Tanner to move
1555 forward for future legislation
further
discussion so I think I I'll just I'll
just add um I believe this um this bill
was recommendations to um uh to make in
this area so uh to help simplify when a
district receives an increased
Grant further discussion I would ditto
what represent luno said uh not seeing
any further discussion Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Nays okay moving on to the next bill HB
1586 establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education I'd like to make a
motion on that rep San luno thank you Mr
chair I'd like to move that we recommend
1586 for future legislation is there a
second of that motion representative
Heath seconds the
motion uh for HB
1586 uh represent luno would you like to
speak to your motion I would just very
briefly 1586 is a comprehensive school
funding reform um uh obviously there's a
lot going on in the courts right now
with respect to um to uh school funding
but uh but I don't think anybody uh in
the state is necessarily looking at our
current uh mechanism for um for funding
schools and saying oh yeah that's
working out really well um so um so
while 1586 is uh currently I think a 26
page Bill and there's a lot to it
there's some things that uh that I think
people like some things that people
maybe don't like so much but I think it
does give us a basis to work from and um
and uh a number of us do intend to uh
bring forward something along these
lines uh during the next uh session
should we be here so um so anyway I
would appreciate everybody's positive
support for this knowing that um that um
that it's it's a complicated situation
but a comprehensive approach is really
discussion okay Madam clerk would you
please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli no
representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no represent Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock
absolutely representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
cascaden yes representative
Damon yes representative Heath yes and
HB 1608 relative providing an induction
teachers yeah I'll make a I'll make a
motion um to recommend 1608 for future
legis legislation I'll
discussion
no NOP I'm
sorry represent Tanner made the second
motion any further discussion from the
committee we're ready when you are Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli no representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representa Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
NS all right going on to the next that's
the same report for that one
10 okay HP 1625 relative to school
health
services is there a motion person
motion I do I would yeah represent
cordelli
no I would uh say uh yes for
recommending for future
legislation is there
oh representative Cornell seconds the
motion made by representative cordelli
this is relative to school health
discussion not seeing any Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes Representative
parall
no representative Cornell
yes representative Tanner
no representative luno yes
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall
yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon
no representative Heath
yes chairman lad yes 16 Y and four
Nays thank
you okay going on down uh looks like we
have one two three four five six7
left HB
1625 no excuse we just did that
1642 relative to the role of Cooperative
School District Board member
Representatives on School District
Peres
cordelli yes I would uh recommend this
for uh future
second represent Noble seconds the
Motion repres cell You' like to speak to
your motion no thank you representa
Noble further discussion from the
committee Madam clerk Vice chairman
cordelli
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes Representative
parshall no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Woodcock no
representative fa no
representative Balon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
representative Heath no and chairman lad
NS
Schools anybody care to make a motion on
that bill no
1646 yep that's your bill yeah thank you
okay representative I I would I would
recommend we bring this forward for
future
legislation and represent Tanner seconds
it okay we have a motion on the floor
for uh
1646 to move it forward for future
legislation made by representative luno
and second by representative Tanner
represent Luna would you would like to
speak to your bill sure sure um just
just briefly there there um there is
some concern uh expressed by both the
Department of Education and the
Department of Justice in terms of um the
um the the legal underpinnings and
Reporting requirements surrounding um uh
uh chartered schools and um and so uh I
do expect to be receiving some uh
recommendations uh from both the
department of Ed and the doj uh with
respect to this and would um would uh uh
I do expect to bring U something along
these lines maybe not the same as
1646 um Ford uh next session should um
um should I be elected again thank you
committee not seeing
any we're ready when you are Madam
clerk the motion is to move the 1646
forward Vice chairman cordelli no
representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no Representative mcdonnald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representative Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
consensus next
one 1657 relative to prohibiting hazing
at educational
institutions
1657 and represent Damon Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion that we recommend
this to come back for further
legislation motion made by represent
Damon
to uh come back with future legislation
down represent
Heath yes okay so we have a motion made
by represent Damon and second by Heath
this is relative to prohibiting hazing
at educational
institutions any further discussion from
the
committee not seeing Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli no
representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representative
Mooney no representative Terry no
representative parall yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes chairman lad no
Nays okay 1670s the next bill this is
relative to including all special
education all special education costs
under State education
grants HB 1670 I'd like to make a motion
represent luno yeah I'd like to move
that we recommend this bill for uh
future
legislation motion made by represent
representative luno second by
representative Damon to move
1670 uh further for future legislation
this is relative to Education costs
under State education grants all special
education
costs further discussion sure just just
briefly Mr chair thank you um uh I would
I I would recommend that this bill be
looked at for future legislation but uh
but in terms of considering uh what the
actual costs are for special education
when uh when calculating the cost
formula uh and um and you know different
than reimbursing every school district
for every cost of special education but
at least considering how these costs
impact the total cost of um of um U of
Education in a school district thank you
any further discussion I will speak to
this a little bit here um we did pass
legislation last year through this
committee by the house
floor and by house
finance to change the formula for
differentiated
unfortunately the Senate didn't see it
our way and we had three categories of
funding for the 13 different IEPs and
that's I know that that type of
legislation is coming back we also had a
number of bills which were dealing with
the the elephant in the room in terms of
special education catastrophic Aid or
special education Aid as we now call it
where the three and a half first three
and a half times the average cost
of a student are paid by the
district we know that's upwards towards
$70,000 and from the three and a half
times to 10 times 80% is paid by the
state and the district has to cough up
that other
20% so there are some real issues in
terms of funding um special
education and whether all costs should
be that of the state or not is a
question and so but that's just some
information for your decision
1670 not see any Madam clerk the motion
is to move it forward for future
legislation Vice chairman cordelli no
representative McDonald no
representative Reed no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
represent Noble no representative Boyd
no representative Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
n HB
1682 real relative to the Civics test
graduation
requirement yes represent
Woodcock do not move forward is there a
second represent Heath makes a second
represent Woodcock made the motion to
move it forward not move it forward for
future legislation this is relative to
Civics test graduation
requirement um I have a little
discussion for that there's a Civics
commission working right now and the Civ
commission is chaired by ID ltin and
representatives are on that I'm on it um
represent moffett's on
it uh Senator Ward's on
it um several
judges are on that uh the Historical
Society for the state is on it and it's
moving along and making some real
wonderful recommendations in terms of uh
complying with hb2 nsv 216 which was a
bill that mandated that Civics be taught
in the middle school and in the high
school along with history Etc there at
the high school and in terms of grades K
through 8 that Civics education
curriculum may be taught embedded within
other subject areas presently being
taught they're making a lot of progress
on this in terms of you know this aspect
and talking about accountability as
well so um there is a an organization
which is tasked to go forward this is
also a result of you know the
appropriation of a million dollars which
we gave that organization that set up
the textbook for this through
hb2 so that's where we stand on that
progress is being made I'm concerned
that that we allow that group to
finalize where they are and coming out
with this report the discovery um what
do you call the the U commercial program
Discovery you see it in television every
now and then too is very much been
contracted as a third party to help
write this curriculum I think I'm seeing
some really pretty good stuff coming out
the Historical Society here is offering
much much information you know moose on
the loose program if you're familiar
with that um that's being incorporated
into the program so that's just some
information to make your decision Mr
yes um I just want to make it clear that
this bill is about the high Stak Civics
test for senior graduation right that's
part of the national uh testing for uh
citizenship we're not talking about
Civics a Civics course per se yeah but
the Civics people are talking this also
it they C of mesh together is that the
way we is that the tool we use to
measure accountability for a Civics
program or for your graduating from high
school does that incorporate everything
in is being measured through that Civics
task
force question that's all thank you
further discussion well the maker of the
motion prer to talk pardon me the maker
of the motion would like to talk yes
thank you um Mr chair I agree with uh
your comments on the work of the
commission and most of the people on the
commission are uh experts in that field
and I think they're uh program
curricular to bring back would be
terrific however this bill uh tends not
to deal with that as representative
Tanis said but rather once again
impacting local school committees to
make the decision on how they evaluate
their youngsters and their students in
the classroom uh and the curriculum that
they use so I don't think the bill
should go forward because once again we
should not be telling local school
boards how they have to test and
evaluate their their own
students uh this goes along with some
other Bill we had about uh immigration
before uh in terms of the same concept
this is should not be a required piece
to tell local school boards the
curriculum you're talking about I think
is superb but the requirement that to
force local school boards to do what we
want down here is not appropriate thank
discussion not seeing any Madam clerk
would you please call the role Vice
chairman
cordelli no
Vice uh representative McDonald no
representative Reid no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Boyd no representative Mooney no
representative Terry no representative
parall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Dan
yes representative he yes and chairman
lad no 10 and 10 1691 relative
definition of inadequate educa public
education
yeah look for a motion represent
cordelli uh I would uh say uh not
recommended um at this time I'll second
that so we have a motion to not
recommend 1691 made by representative
cordelli second by represent luno
further discussion from maker or the
second not seeing
it uh further discussion from the
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Nays and the last bill on the doct Today
is SP 375 relative to biological sex in
student
Athletics represent
recommended represent Damon seconds the
motion made by representa cordelli to
not recommend for future legislation s
SP 375 representa cordelli uh thank you
uh we passed legislation uh this past
year HB 1205 it was signed into law um
it is currently in the courts I believe
um so I see no need for this uh bill um
in the next legislative session as we
already have a law on the books gson
Damon I don't believe there was ever a
you and this version of law also would
extend the the uh um use of this bill to
postsecondary education and the Bill 125
went middle high school so there there
there's significant difference in the
discussion Madam clerk we're ready when
you're ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Reed yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Boyd yes representative Mooney yes
representative Terry yes representative
parshall yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes and chairman lad yes 20 a zero
n well that takes us down the list that
we have here for day 24 of them um those
bills which do not come with the unable
to read consensus of whether to
recommend further legislation or not
those bills will all have that line the
other bills though we do need to have
the reports
completed so if you're if you made a
motion where it wasn't you know a 1010
you need to get those reports done also
for the committee those that are on
the
uh oversight committee for improvement
and assessment the 306 rules are coming
up what's the date on that 17th on the
17th and we are dealing with um the
second half but also some of the first
half issues need to be
discussed so um if you're interested uh
please read up on that and so when we
come in here we can move there's a lot
of stuff in there which needs discussion
so I encourage everybody to take a look
yes we look at believe at our last
meeting we were working off with
different yeah you can go to the doe
website now I went there just last night
and they had the first half and the
second half with the and with the dates
that they were the most recent do copies
and shows red where it's been added or
deleted
so check it out Jen
have could you please make you know how
many people are on the that either the
the Jo the Jael car group and that's the
group where we have a responsibility to
review all three all administrative
rules or on the other how many people we
have on that so we can get some copies
made for
everybody no there's
only and
I three and two no it's four to two four
to two
so so could you please you know make
make it about eight copies please of
each the front half and the back half so
so on the on those copies Mr chair and
and this is actually for for anybody
else that that is because there a lot of
people that are following this the um
the redlining or the change tracking on
that is not change tracking back to the
current rules it's only change tracking
back to whatever prior draft was worked
on by the Department of Education so so
when looking at that when looking at the
drafts with change tracking on don't
don't assume that anything that isn't
redlined um how do I say it the there
may be things that aren't redlined that
are still changes from current from
current rule uh so it's it's very
difficult to uh to see how things are
changed without doing a side by side
yeah yeah excuse me chairman lad may I
make a request yes um that that link
gets sent to all of us on the committee
because I know when I go on the doe
website I get lost so I would appreciate
just having a specific link so that I
can find them thank you yeah you go to
the section has administrative rules and
then you go down several links down
we'll get that to you we'll get that to
everybody um the other thing I wanted to
speak to everybody about there's been
some concern throughout the state that
local municipalities are going through
reassessments of property
values and the my particular town is one
of them and not doing it in a 5year
cycle but doing it on a three-year
cycle and some of those re aows are
coming out as high as 78 80% on top of
what they have been in the past the
questions that I have been asking over
to
doe to the finance people and to
Dr is that yes we we do know that
changes are being made in terms of
market value current market value of
these Residential Properties and
Commercial
properties and we have what we call an
equalized property ratio which shows you
where the reeval is in terms of the
market value if you got 100 it means
they're 100% they're there together but
if you have like a 58 or something such
as that it means your assessment
properties only 58% of what the market
is driving right now or the current
market within the last year or so and my
the concern that folks are raising is we
have a number of areas within our
finance formula which are based off of
property values
uh such as the extraordinary needs Grant
which is on the right hand side Mary you
know that on the right hand side the
leftand side is a base differentiated
Aid stuff on the right hand side you
have this extraordinary need and it's
based upon equiz property valuation
including those things such as utilities
and railroads but divided by the number
of kids that qualify for fnr free and
reduced
meals and we're seeing with the re
values that some of these um change Es
are impacting the extraordinary need
grant funding and districts are starting
to filter through that and see the
consequences of that now so if you hear
anything about it my suggestion is you
contact doe and Dr and try to get a
handle on that um it's something that we
as a legislature are going to have to
address represent L do you have anything
for this say on that because we talked
earlier today about it sure um yeah um
chair lad and I are going to are going
to get together with um we're looking to
get together with some some
representatives from the Department of
Revenue Administration to really
understand what the impact is on um on
some of these um um school funding
grants obviously it's of of great
concern right now and actually I I had
concern about that even when those
grants were when the language for those
were being developed because they were
so tightly coupled with valuations
during a during a very
you know um unusual uh real estate
market and and uh and so
um so I I I I I I think we're all you
know seeing seeing our communities go
through this I'm certainly seeing it in
hopkington where people are lined up
getting into town hall uh you know
because they're so surprised at the uh
the change in the valuations but uh but
where the real surprise is going to be
is in the um in the state grants um to
school districts that are based on
valuation so we're going to need to take
a very careful look about how we you
know whether we Factor valuation into
grants down the road and how we make
sure that those grants are or the the um
how the valuations are calculated that
can keep up with changes in in you know
in the in the real market right the
equalization they're all doing this then
fine but they're all all the towns are
not doing it so it's not going to be
equal and if you're doing this out of
sync of the five years you know right
now we're in a moment in time where the
market values are really up and and uh
so it is a concern and school boards my
school board has recognized that my
community is seeing where the commercial
properties are not jumping but the
Residential Properties are jumping by
twice you so you're seeing 80% plus
increases and that is very difficult and
the concern we have is Workforce housing
for young people moving into the state
where they're seeing these prices now
they can't afford to find a place and so
your towns having a hard time attracting
people there's there's young families
so keep in tune if you if you get hit
with something as a representative you
know I would I would call doe and Dr and
and try and get a better understanding
what's going on or or reach out or reach
out
yeah okay thank you very much that
concludes it's noon and thank you very
much for your hard work
today done yeah